nach 80 langen tagen auf dem segelboot
ganz alleine rund um die welt heute
endlich wieder an land der deutsche
abenteuer weltumsegler boris herrmann
endlich wieder bei seiner familie
bei seinem sieben monate alten kind sein
sportlicher wettkampf das war die wende
globe ein kampf gegen fünf meter wellen
notrufe schon nach 22 tagen weiter
machen weiter segeln dann weihnachten
unter deck mit einer lichterkette am
bordcomputer immer wieder schäden am
boot das segelfliegen und schließlich
ist er dann ganz kurz vorm ziel hat
einen spitzenplatz in sichtweite so gute
chancen aufs podium zu kommen und dann
passiert dann kommt für boris herrmann
zum filmreifen drama die spuren von
boris herrmann siegel drama in der
biskaya vor einer halben stunde hatte
ich einen zusammenstoß mit einem
fischerboot gefasst schilderte boris
herrmann wie am mittwochabend sein
großer traum zerplatzte nur wenige
stunden vor dem ziel der segel regatta
vendée globe hatte der weltumsegler
einen unfall
damit waren alle chancen auf einen
podiumsplatz bei seiner premiere da hin
zum zeitpunkt des vorfalls war er
dritter und hatte wegen einer
zeitgutschrift von sechs stunden sogar
noch chancen auf den sieg bei dem
zusammenstoß mit dem fischerboot etwa
165 kilometer vor dem ziel
verfügen sie sich unter anderem ein vor
säge in den kränen des trawlers und ein
tragflügel seines bootes brach wie es zu
dem zusammenstoß kommen konnte ist für
hermann unklar
noch am mittwochnachmittag hatten alle
waren systeme an bord seiner explorer
einwandfrei funktioniert
alles hat perfekt funktioniert bei jedem
boot dem ich begegnet bin
und selbst nach dem unfall hatte ich
keinen alarm an bord der 39 jährige
hamburger konnte die fahrt in richtung
der französischen hafenstadt le havre
dollar nach kurzen notreparaturen nur
noch mit reduzierter geschwindigkeit
fortsetzen und sich am ende platz vier
sichern
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren